bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france sont nicole
pashinian qui dénonce donc un coup
d'état militaire un putsch est ce que
c'est bien le cas ce qu'on peut utiliser
ces mots-là restons-nous blast au mans
ça commençait par en fait cv pashinian
qui a commencé par limogé le chef
d'état-major adjoint
il ya eu une réaction de chef d'état
major qui a signé une déclaration avec
le énormément d'officiers d'officiers
supérieurs une grande partie de l'état
majeur demandant la démission de
pachinian et à la suite de sap à chignon
a limogé le chef d'état-major
donc on est encore dans un dans un bras
de fer mais pas encore dans un coup
d'état
peut-être ne sera jamais si ça se règle
en douceur l'opposition n'a jamais
pardonné à nikol pashinian la défaite
arménienne lors du dernier conflit haut
karabagh baisse toujours que ton quand
on subit une défaite on cherche des
boucs émissaires on cherche le
responsable
la vérité est que pashinian est assez
peu responsables c'est la préparation
précédant de et des erreurs
diplomatiques sur de longues années qui
ont conduit à ce à ce désastre pour
l'armée arménienne
il ne reste pas moins que la solution
actuelle le cessez-le-feu est l'état qui
en résulte n'est pas si défavorables en
fait à l'arménie parce que l'arménie n'a
pas perdu formellement le haut karabakh
les armes nerfs continue à y vivre le
couloir de latchine reste surveillé par
les russes c'est donc qu'il peut
communiquer avec l'arménie peut
communiquer avec le haut karabakh
la seule chose qui a perdu en fait
l'armée ni ses sept districts dont
l'arménie elle même considéré qu'il
n'était pas armé niamey que c'était
simplement une zone de sécurité
donc en fait l'accord du 10 novembre
à moscou et un accord qui est plutôt
favorable à l'arménie sur le plan
diplomatique
compte tenu de l'échec militaire qu'elle
avait subis donc en fait l'intérêt des
arméniens serait plutôt de de garder les
choses en l'état et de ne pas provoquer
de deux changements ne pouvoir qui
risquerait d'amener au pouvoir des
reventes schiste et de relancer un
conflit qui pour l'instant en tout cas
compte tenu du rapport de force ne
jouerait pas en faveur de l'arménie
alors nikol pashinian tout cas peut
compter sur des soutiens on les a vu
défiler dans les rues d'airé vannes cet
après midi vingt mille soutien selon
l'afm et enfin il ya quand même eu de
l'autre côté en face à un défilé
d'opposants ça veut dire clairement qu
on a une armée ni divisée oui l'arménie
divisées et c'est toujours ennuyeux
d'avoir d'avoir l'armé contre soi parce
que quand on regarde les signataires de
la déclaration demandant le départ de
pachinian il ya quasiment tout l'état
major une majorité des officiers
supérieurs dont il a divorcé entre
pashinian et la remettre et ça
évidemment dans un état de semi guerre
ou en tout cas la sortie de la guerre
cessez le feu qui quand même vaste
précaire malgré les forces de maintien
de la paix russes c'est un milieu pas
signés alors en tout cas washington
semble avoir pris position d'une
certaine manière en tout cas puisque
washington appelle ce soir à l'instant
d'ailleurs les forces armées à ne pas
intervenir dans les affaires politiques
au sujet donc de l'arménie que vous
inspire cette sortie certainement du
département peut-être d'anthony dean
cain mais on ne sait pas encore mais que
vous inspire cette déclaration
américaine ce soir mais écoutez ce que
ce qui est notable c'est que le
président poutine téléphone à pashinian
le président r 2 one en tout cas les
autorités turques marque lors leur
soutien indirect c'est un peu le baiser
qui tue mais enfin quand même pas
chinian le le département d'état
soutient pashinian jeu
que tout le monde considère que l'accord
du dinosaure éteint est un équilibre
relativement satisfaisant et tout le
monde s'inquiètent d'une déstabilisation
nouvelles de la région comme angers
tellement peut-on sortir de cette
division de ce conflit interne à l'armée
nie désormais c'est dit c'est difficile
à dire parce que de toute façon il
faudra que il me semble je suis pas un
spécialiste des affaires arménienne mais
il me semble que dans la psychologie
collective arménienne il faudra
nécessairement un bouc émissaire pour la
défaite militaire et la question de
savoir qui sera le bouc émissaire n'est
pas encore réglé et c'est là toute la
difficulté
merci jean de gliniasty d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france